What do you think, David?
>> So I said that four of them
could represent a 3D object.
This could be a cylinder.
This is some kind of trapezoidal prism,
and this kind of looks like a pyramid
from above with the top blocked off.
We gotta see this as looking
down at some kind of pyramid or
we might also see this
as looking into a box.
This one is a bit of
an interesting example.
It doesn't as naturally lend itself
to interpretation as a 3D figure.
But at the same time, we can imagine
that that's what you would get if you
looked at this figure directly down.
>> David, it is interesting that you did
not pick this as an answer, as well.
I guess I would have picked that one.
I see this as an x-axis,
the y-axis, and the z-axis.
And because all three axis
can be identified here,
I would have thought of this, too,
as an example of a 3D object.
>> That's interesting, Ashok.
Now that you mention it,
I can't stop seeing it as a 3D object.
Now I see it as kind of a folded
piece of paper that just has a line
drawn at the center.
Initially, I don't think I
looked at that as a 3D object,
because I saw the lines as having to
represent places where the figure
folded or where different planes met.
But if we look at the line at the middle
as just kind of something drawn
on the figure, it immediately
pops out as a 3D object for me.
>> And this brings us to
the point of this exercise.
The point of the exercise is that
clearly some kind of processing is
agreeing in our visual system.
That allows us to group these lines and
these surfaces in ways.
So that we can identify which
one of them is a 3D object, and
which one of them is not a 3D object.
Clearly, this processing is
not completely definitive,
in that sometimes it is ambiguity.
You might come up with one answer to
this, and someone else may come up with
a slightly different to this because the
processing leaves room for ambiguity.